I love a romantic story
Nick walked up to you at an Oscar party
the first time and grabbed your hand on
the way out and he got down on one knee
and he said
Priyanka you're real where have you been
all my life now why then
was it like a year or so after that
incident why did you wait so long to
really get romantic with him it was such
a prince charming moment it was like
time stopped and also he was like so hot
and like I didn't know him and it I was
at the Vanity Fair party it was really
like a meat cute from a movie and he
just held my hand and I turned around
and he was in his suit and he goes down
on his knees and I was like
and I think time stopped I was on my way
to at the Vanity Fair party they have in
and out burger stand and I was on my way
to cook at that Burger and even that
like I just it was all slow motion you
run off and what is it like a year later
he finally like I don't know something
at the Met Gala he he ran into you there
at the the Met Gala where we didn't go
with each other somehow we landed at the
same time on the carpet and I look I was
fixing my adjusting my dress and I look
up and it was like oh of course it's
naked the medcal at the same time as me
and we talked a little bit and he was
like let's just give it a real shot and
I was like yeah sure of course I wasn't
looking for a relationship at that time
it was just I was just like I need to
figure out where my where my grounding
is where do I live do I live in America
do I live in India where's my career
where's my family I don't have friends
right now I'm like I just didn't have
ground under my feet and and so is he
texting you at this point with no ground
under your feet and he's saying hey come
on let's go on a date he asked me out on
a few amazing dates one of them was the
White House for I think President
Obama's
did you go no
look at your dates he asked me for it
was his
um a farewell dinner or some something
I'm not sure
but you said no why would you do that I
was afraid of
um you know getting into anything at
that time I was afraid like of getting
my heart broken I was afraid of
of just I had just been through the
ringer and I was just like you had been
burned in your previous relationship
yeah so where was the real date where
did you guys go we went to watch or he
was smart he told me he's like I have a
few tickets I'm going with my friends if
you would like to come so he disarmed Me
by not having the pressure of just him
and I he had three of his friends I
brought a friend of mine we went to
tickets to what beauty and the beast of
the Hollywood Bowl
oh that's smart take you somewhere yeah
and then and then like if he's bombing
in the conversation at least there's
someone to watch and and I have
something to watch and I have friends to
talk to but we get all decked out for
that did you like put on one of those
hot outfits no I forgot what I was
wearing but my husband remembers he said
I wore jeans and a jacket too
yeah I guess I wanted to play it cool
too you know he's a rock star and
everything like I don't want to play all
your cards so the no alone time at that
point and then finally you guys the next
day
um that night we spent like so many
hours just eight hours or something all
of us together and him and I would just
buy each other's side and he asked me
the next day to go to a Dodgers game now
I don't know my baseball for my football
you know I'm like just me too a little
bit unaware
um but I was very excited to go have
alone time with him and I felt
butterflies I woke up early and it was
just like a feeling I hadn't felt in a
long time and it just was
from the uphill from there I would think
dating a musician too is hard because
does he ever say to you honey I just
wrote a song about you yes the first
time he did that Howard now
oh my God right that was a good night
for him I bet
where are you when he announces to you
that he's written a song about you where
are you so the best place to listen to
music is in the car when you listen to
it for the first time and listen to a
song because the Acoustics are just
amazing so we're driving I think to
lunch
uh I think it was a Beverly Hills Hotel
or something
um and he goes
play what I wrote today is that cool and
he still plays music exactly like this
he's like yeah it was in the studio just
like we'll play something from today
cool cool plays this song and uses words
and phrases that are very me
um and phrases that I've used and I
didn't want to presume it so I didn't
say anything I was like oh that's a
that's an awesome song and he was like
yeah does it sound familiar and I was
like a few words he's like well I wrote
this for you and I start tearing up no
because I didn't want to presume that it
was for me or about me
um and I just said it was a really good
song and he asked me if it was familiar
and I said a few things on like things
I've said to you and he said
and this is what was the feel the deal I
think he said look I'm not a man of too
many words but my songs will be my love
letters to you
and
you know that's pretty [__] good line
yeah
[Music]
and then you guys got engaged after two
months of dating which is unbelievable
married five months later and you know
you know
foreign